I am now setting the goal of 100,000
tests per day by the end of this month
that is the goal and I am determined
that we will get there and to help drive
this work forward I'm pleased that
Professor John Newton from public health
England will be taking on a new role to
coordinate this national effort for
testing working with my brilliant
departmental officials the NHS and the
life sciences industry professor Newton
is widely recognized as a leading voice
on public health and epidemiology and
I'm thrilled that we can bring to bear
his considerable experience on this
vital issue my five pillars represent a
comprehensive plan to put in place the
testing that is mission critical as we
fight this battle against coronavirus
there will be problems like many of
those that we've already overcome after
all building a brand new industry it's
not easy
there will be bumps in the road and
criticisms made and some of them will be
justified and I returned from illness
more determined than ever to fight this
disease will bring together the best
minds will bring together the best
science that this country has to offer